[Música]
se você acha que eu fui contratado pela
equipe de manutenção do porto
você está enganado hoje ele falar sobre
outra coisa sobre o telhado verde em
eu e minha família fizemos uma viagem
para a dinamarca e lá descobrimos que o
povo dinamarquês tem muitas formas
legais de interagir com a natureza
entre os o telhado verde isto é uma lei
que obriga a todos os edifícios com uma
loja reta até o telhado verde a
descobrir me sentir surpreso
achei uma coisa revolucionária coisa que
faltava no brasil
quando eu me interessei mais sobre o
assunto eu pesquisei mais e descobrir
que esta lei foi criada para melhorar a
forma de vida dos cidadãos à dinamarca
para testar se é realmente difícil fazer
literário do verde e minha mãe fizemos
em casa lá descobrimos que não era tão
difícil quanto a chave mas vamos em
torno de duas horas para fazê lo e se
você quer fazer um terá que se
comprometer e se dedicar ao telhado
verde mas no final fica legal
mas como fazer um telhado verde
estas são imagens de fazer um telhado
verde e primeiros ficarei como fizemos
pesquisas na internet material
necessário e fomos uma loja local
depois voltando pra casa pegamos uma
escada isso - o telhado não esqueça de
levar um adulto vai tentar fazer sozinho
a lama nova da água também é bem útil
não será necessária cinco camadas
a primeira uma camada de verniz besant
manta asfáltica com lona plástica que
serve para evitar que a loja sofreu
infiltrações em segundo ou uma camada de
plástico resistente que serve para
evitar que as raízes perfuraram telhado
em terceiro uma camada de material
poroso que serve para armazenar água das
chuvas
no caso usamos amanda dividir esticamos
escolhamos ela cobrirá a loja inteira
lembrando de deixar umas folgas nas
pontas para depois de uma viradinha
não deixaram escapar quando chega na
ponta eu olhei para baixo
nossa candidatura eu esperei e seguir em
frente é quarto com uma camada de argila
expandida pneus picadas ou até mesmo
carvão que serve para sustentar as
raízes reter nutrientes e absorver a
água da chuva
as despedidas são essas bolinhas marrons
extremamente leves
depois é claro uma camada de terra
adubada em quinto e último lugar uma
camada de grama flores arbustos e até
pequenas árvores é possível fazer
pequenas hortas mais recomendadas
plantas que sobreviveu mais tempo sem
água
nós colhemos as plantas e chora e cróton
são plantas bonitas mas bem práticas que
não precisa de muito cuidado
outras vantagens do telhado verde ao
conforto térmico que engloba a redução
das ilhas de calor
a diminuição do aquecimento global a
melhoria do microclima e é claro a
temperatura confortável do edifício que
tem o telhado verde
ele fica mais fresco no verão e mais
quente no inverno algumas curiosidades
sobre o telhado verde são que nem é
permeável e um sistema de drenagem além
disso ele proporcionando conforto visual
deixando casas
além disso ele prometeu no conforto
visual deixando casas e prédios muito
bonitos
esse tipo de telhado também melhores
condições do que é assim que ficou o meu
telhado verde e se você gostou e se
fecha e telhado e deixa melhor tudo
[Aplausos]
[Música]